-Our next guest
is a very funny comedian
you know from her viral lip-sync
videos of President Trump.
Her new special,
"Everything's Fine,"
is streaming now on Netflix.
Let's take a look.
-Pres. Trump:
Maybe it's a different one
-Man: It better not
be the publicist.
No, it's her. It's her.
-Yeah, that's her with the gold.
I got to use some Tic Tacs jus
in case I start kissing her.
You know, I'm automaticall
attracted to beautiful --
I just start kissing them.
It's like a magnet.
You just kiss.
-[ Laughter ]
-I don't even wait.
Hey, when you're a star,
they let you do it.
You just kiss.
You just -- You can do anything.
-Please welcome to the sho
Sarah Cooper.
How are you, Sarah?
-I'm good. That was
some good editing there.
Cut it off right before
the big line.
-Oh, no.
We'll make sure we get it in
We'll get it in for the rerun.
Hey, it's so nice to meet you.
I, like many people,
was introduced to you
via these videos you made
where you lip-sync Donald Trum
and in a way that I think
presented the words
that he was saying in a wa
that we weren't used to seeing
and really laid bare
how little sense he made.
When did you realize
that this was an effective way
to present him
and what he was saying?
-Um, I think I realized that
after people started
sharing them
and getting really excited
about them
and the news media
was really getting into them
because for them,
they have to be impartial,
and so this was
a really succinct way
of showing
how empty his words were
without having to do
any, like, editorializing.
And so that was really
when it hit
that it was newsworthy as well
as entertaining and funny.
And I think people just
really enjoy being able to laugh
without having to see his face
and that was kind of
the big difference
between what I do and what mos
sort of "impressionists" do.
And I don't even really call i
an impression.
But I think when that vide
where he was talking about
injecting, you know, Lysol
into his veins went viral,
I realized that people
were really excited to see
Trump's words come out
of my mouth for some reason.
-With that said,
a lot of people wonder
not just about someone like you,
but someone like me --
they would ask,
"Are you disappointed
that he lost the election?
Is it safe to say that is as not
true for you as it is for me
-I am so happy.
I'm so happy, but I'm more
relieved than anything els
because, to be honest, Tuesday
it wasn't looking good
for Democrats,
and I was looking at my videos
and I was like,
"If he wins,
these won't be funny anymore."
If he was actually able
to escape everything
that we've tried
to get rid of him,
including me with these videos
trying to point out to everyon
how he was completely
incompetent,
then these videos
would just be sad.
But now that he's lost,
they're even more hysterical
So I'm very relieved for that.
-They will have a far longer
shelf life, I agree.
You have -- I've noticed
you mentioned that he has
blocked you on Twitter.
I assume...
-Yeah.
-...that the President
blocked you on Twitter
because of the videos,
but it actually predated that?
-Yep. In 2017, I responded
to one of his tweets.
I was one of the angry one
responding to all of his tweets.
And I said that he was unfit
for office, and he blocked me.
And he has still blocked m
to this day.
I checked just today,
and I'm still blocked.
It's very sad.
He's very fragile,
very sensitive man.
I can't imagine what he's
going on through right now
but I think, you know --
Do you remember
that time where somebody
accidentally deleted
his Twitter account
for like a few hours?
-Yeah.
-We need to bring that guy back.
Let's just --
It just needs to go --
He needs to stop tweeting.
I know he would love
to continue,
but we need to move on.
We have to move on.
We have to move on, Seth!
-Yes. I think it seems like he's
more than ready to move on
He seems to be taking it
very well.
-Yeah.
-I want to ask about this,
as well, that some Trump fan
in watching your videos
maybe responded more positivel
than you would have thought.
-Yeah.
I mean, at first, I was like
"Maybe they don't realize
that I'm making fun of him?"
You know, maybe they're watching
this, and they're like,
"Oh, a Black woman
who likes Trump!
Maybe I'm not racist after all."
You know?
And I would get comments like,
"I love Trump,
but this is hysterical,"
and so I'm like,
"What are you laughing at?
But now I think it's just --
You can enjoy them
on multiple levels.
On one level, you can see, like,
the satire and the irony
of what is happening,
and another level,
it's just, like, bizarre
to see his voice
coming out of my mouth
and the facial expressions
I make, so...
I'm okay with it now.
I've come to accept it.
Especially since he lost,
I'm okay with it.
If he had won and then peopl
had pointed to me like,
"Oh, maybe she actually
helped him with these videos,"
then I would have been --
I would have been distraught
-You -- I want to talk about
the Netflix special, as well
You have a ton
of great guest stars.
Helen Mirren, as we saw
in the clip, Jon Hamm.
Natasha directed it.
And then Fred Armisen, as well
our band leader.
And you were -- Is it true
that you were excited
to be working with Fred?
-I was super excited.
I met Fred,
like, seven years ago
at a South by Southwest panel.
I took a picture with him
afterwards.
And I -- I was just,
like, a huge fan of his.
And when I was working wit
Natasha Lyonne,
who was director of the special,
she was texting me.
And she said, "Fred's here
and Fred, you know, read
some of the stuff,
and he likes it."
And I was like, "Oh, my God.
Fred Armisen is reading this
and he's liking it?
This is incredible."
And then Natasha said,
"Fred thinks that
you don't know who he is."
And I said, "What?" Yeah.
Apparently, he truly believe
that I didn't know who he was.
And so I was able
to send this picture as proo
that I knew exactly who he was
-There you go. There's a -
-Yeah.
And I even got his glasses
I mean, I was a big fan.
I even used to --
I didn't tell him this,
so I hope
he's not watching this,
but I used to own the domain
FredArmisenFans.com.
[ Laughter ]
-I'm assuming you flipped that
for a pretty penny.
-I mean, I was hoping Fred
would come back at some poin
and be like,
"I need this domain, Sarah
I'll give you a million dollar
for it."
But it just never happened
-Well, now he knows
it's out there.
By the way,
that really is a story.
And, Fred,
I do hope you're watching.
That's a story about Fred
being very needy.
-[ Laughter ]
-Is it?
I thought it was humility.
Is it neediness?
-No, it's like, "I don't think
she knows who I am."
Come on, Fred. Fred!
-Fred, you fooled me.
-You've had a really --
I mean, it's been a crazy year
for a lot of people,
but your year has had
a lot of very positive thing
that maybe would have been har
to predict
at the beginning of the year
You guest hosted
for Jimmy Kimmel.
You appeared at the DNC.
Were you able to take stoc
and appreciate the year
you were having
as it was happening?
-No, I wasn't.
It was -- It just --
You know, this year
has been so emotionally draining
that I feel like I was
experiencing all these emotion
and I just didn't have tim
to process them.
Like, it just hit me
that I was in bed with Jon Hamm.
Like, I -- It still
hasn't even really hit me ye
that that actually happened.
And I think in a year,
maybe it will hit me again
But it will --
It's just so strange
because, you know, yes,
a lot has changed,
but, at the same time,
I'm still just, you know,
at home working from home.
You know, I'm doing all thes
interviews from home.
Like, so a lot has changed
but then nothing has changed
It's been -- It's really weird
But everyone is telling me
to really enjoy this moment,
so I'm trying to enjoy thi
moment, but at the same time
everything feels very surreal.
-Well, we certainly enjoye
having you here.
Congratulations on everything.
It's been great to speak to yo
and great to meet you.
-Thank you so much, Seth.
It was awesome meeting you
And I have SethMeyersFans, too
-That's the one Fred's
going to want to buy.
"Everything's Fine"
is streaming on Netflix.